the Doha Waterfront called the Corniche
will host a month-long Carnival during
Qatar 2022
the primary artery for cars will be
transformed into a pedestrian-only
Entertainment District for an estimated
1.2 million fans it's an extra ordinary
experience if we talk about having
people walk on the street you know
having the street all pedestrianized
Waterfront with all kiosks with all
shops restaurants cafes lighting it's
it's an enjoyable space I would believe
the compact nature of this year's World
Cup means traffic congestion in a
condensed area as people travel around a
small country where most of the
population lives in the capital
the hope is as many as half the fans
attending matches will use Doha Metro it
debuted in 2019. 110 cars will make up
to 700 000 trips in each day the red
lines can carry 1 000 people every 165
seconds which can handle the demand of
the of the expectator but anyhow like
this is the nature of the tournament all
the spectators should expect some delays
controlling crowds and keeping the peace
at football's Premier event is every
host country's greatest challenge
[Applause]
nearly 50 000 security Personnel have
been trained and multiple exercises have
been held with International Partners to
prepare for Qatar 2022.
we work hand in hand with FIFA we are
confident with the plans that we have in
place Safety and Security forces of of
the utmost importance
whether it's navigating the journey or
the crowds at a match or concert the
organizing committee says planning and
patience will create an enjoyable and
safe World Cup experience for all
Natasha ganane Al Jazeera Doha